hello uh there's been a lot of things
happening in a very short amount of time
just in the past two weeks so if you've
heard crazy rumors about me uh most of
them might be true some might not I'm
just going to make a blanket statement
that some of them might not be true but
a lot of them have been true in the past
two weeks while I was in Austin filming
more for my movie and somehow I think
breaking the record for most blood in a
horror movie yay and I'm trying to
calculate the numbers to prove that
that's a whole another story not
relating to anything to do with this
um again we'll get into that at a very
much later date and then I was in the
hospital because uh blood was in my eyes
so if you saw a picture online of me
with the most horrifying oh I talked
about this God I this is so weird I
don't even remember that I didn't update
talking about that because immediately
after that I get a text from my mom
saying that my Grandma's not doing well
and so I have to book a flight to go go
out to Korea and literally the next day
after that my grandma passed away and I
know this probably seems like I'm being
very blase about this update
um but in reality the trip that I went
on and the ability to go out there it
was very hard to do but at the same time
the experience was incredibly cathartic
in the way that my Korean family was
honoring my grandma was extremely
helpful in the healing process and I was
able to move through it and also just
like it was just a crazy arduous time
with the lack of sleep the blood in my
eyes and then after I got there I got an
ear infection and then I experienced
firsthand the wonder that was the Korean
Health Care System there's so much that
went on in this past week and a half and
I would love to go over all the details
but I actually have talked about this
now twice both to the members and also
on the podcast and I know I I make the
disclaimer being like Hey listen to the
podcast
um but honestly we weren't even able to
keep up with those episodes because this
just all happened so suddenly
um so I do apologize for not having
videos but at the same time I kind of
don't apologize for not having videos
because I think all of you can
understand that family will come first
family always comes first and the family
always should come first if your family
matters to you that has been mine very
much does and I very much matter to my
family so I was very happy to be able to
just kind of go and be there for them I
wasn't able to be there when my grandma
passed but I was be able to be there
during the ceremony and during all of
the different things that I had to do
and The Cremation bearing her and it was
really really healing and really good
and so I'm back
um and I do want to get back into videos
because I really do feel
good I feel
very very at peace with it I feel like
so much has happened in the past two
weeks that comparatively it's just like
one of those moments where I just like I
really like to appreciate you know what
I'm able to do and I'm so glad that I
still to this day get joy out of what I
do and I I still really love waking up
and being able to do this
um and I want to want to capitalize on
that Joy but that doesn't mean that I'm
like gonna destroy myself trying to get
back into videos it's going to be an
easing process I want to finish Amnesia
so bad it's so good
um it's terrifying and it's just like
it's captivating and there's so many
other games obviously that I want to
play there's even some recordings that
we made that I wasn't able to get up all
the way because obviously I was away and
there's another story in there about how
I lost my bag on the flight over so I
arrived in Korea with no luggage I
didn't have any clothes I didn't have
any toiletries I didn't have anything I
stole the pillow from the airline
it's kind of nice so I'll link in the
description there's an episode of
distractible that I think came out today
uh if not I'll update it when it does
come out but it literally was just me
basically talking about this entire
experience in Greater detail if you want
to know the details
the short version of it is
hospital my grandma passed away was able
to be there in Korea for the funeral was
able to be there with my family in Korea
was able to share uh the documentary
that I made for my mom which did have my
grandma in it and talked a lot about my
grandpa and I was able to show that to
my family in a very poorly translated
version of it but you know I was able to
do that and so that was
that was really special and I'm I'm glad
I took the time to do that but I am back
and there's a lot to do but I'm loving
doing it so I'm gonna keep this
relatively short remember if you want
the full version of the story it's it's
down there in the description it's not a
push for the podcast and enough of you
already know it exists I know that's not
what this is about it's just if you want
to get the full story
um yeah just thank you guys so much for
understanding and thank you for being
here for me and uh thank you for
you know just allowing me to do this
crazy thing that I do so thank you
see you in the next one
bye-bye